hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
season six of fortnight Battle Royale
has been and gone so now's the time to
look back at all those Easter eggs
cultural references a few memes and all
the in-game shenanigans which in season
six was all about the last days of Kevin
the cube can I get some FS in chat for
Kevin before we go any further the
greatest Easter egg in season six is
simple it's this older members alright
I'm not being serious there are far
better ones than that let's do this so
season six began on September 27th 2018
and ended on December 5th with the theme
of darkness rises basically this was all
leading up to the season when save the
world would become free-to-play I was so
hyped for more players to join the
battle against the husks and it's not
free oh ok anyway let's start with the
spooky bus pass which included a but
turn of unlockables
let's break down where they all began
life remember when the factories and the
nightclub were added near flush factory
well they didn't have a name twitch
variety streamer CD and the third dubbed
it yonder yard and the community adopted
that he was actually trying to find a
new home after the king of dusty had
found his home destroyed in season 4 the
first character we unlock on the season
6 battle pass is none other than DJ
yonder in homage to CD n this is the
second time CD and the third was
immortalized in the game after his
positivity in molt popped up a few
seasons back the other character
unlocked in the battle past is calamity
and a first look she looks like a coyote
ugly reject coincidentally that's a
really good film you should go and watch
it the reason why I bring this up though
is due to the song which released with
that film can't fight the moonlight
which ties in perfectly with the theme
of Halloween and the beasts and
creatures calamity will be hunting as
she levels up werewolves and vampires
over time the calamity becomes a
full-fledged vampire hunter with a
costume very reminiscent of many films
in particular van Helsing that isn't a
great film tour
that one here's the greatest touch of
Aldo the insignias and patterns around
her coat they are inspired by another
movie underworld this one is all about
Kate Beckinsale's character Selena who's
a vampire who hunts werewolves back to
the battle pass and Martin lockable
characters these ones take on the theme
of fairy tales
you know because Halloween is all about
people dressing up in random things like
a sexy nurse what the heck does a sexy
nurse have to do with Halliwell she's
got blood she's got a bit as fine his
fine it's fine get with the program
so the fabled Red Riding set is
obviously based on the story of Red
Riding Hood and her run-in with the wolf
dressed as grandma but in this
alternative universe
she made a pie out of the wolf judging
by that glider season 6 brought us pets
and anyone who saw them instantly loved
the little cute buggers I didn't get the
pink hamster I asked for last season but
we did get a dog a dragon and a
chameleon did you get the feeling that
they instantly looked familiar this is
due to the design style used it doesn't
follow Fortnight conventions it instead
uses Disney or DreamWorks methods to
build characters the chameleon camo is
designed to resemble the look and more
importantly the mannerisms of Pascal
from tangled the dog bonzi takes classic
Disney properties like the 101
Dalmatians and injects it with pixar
skills like bolt the pet which doesn't
follow Disney models is the dragon
scales I originally thought this was a
nod to Spyro as the remaster of that
game released at the same time as season
stakes and the proportions matched up
well but then I watched how to train
your dragon dreamworks created this
movie franchise but do you know which
company distributes this yep it's none
other than Disney anyway what I'm
suggesting here is that by incorporating
design elements from established
creative forces like Disney can make new
characters instantly feel familiar so
did it work on you
[Music]
just before we move on from the theme of
fairy tales did you notice the Three
Little Pigs houses scattered around the
map they decided to replace hay with a
far stronger substance metal get into
that wolfy and now the final unlock in
season six is battle Pass
none other than Dyer the original
character model is designed to look like
Johnny from The Karate Kid
as he upgrades he even gets his
nunchucks but at that point
another 80s masterpiece takes over Teen
Wolf the original film has a serialized
remake recently but I'm talking about
the og cinematic story Michael J Fox
getting to that age where hair grows
everywhere you know in weird place only
balls that's a lot of fur some people
believe that this skin is actually in
homage to three streamers T foo as the
character is a default and strangely he
actually looks like that ninja because
he's wearing a bandana and in its final
form this could be Dakota's spirit
animal the wolf I'm not on board with
that theory but I do I do like the sound
of it looking at emote the running man
popped up in season six it was
originally a craze in the 1980s but then
it was a bit more pronounced but then
vine and these two geezers in particular
showed up and the running man challenge
took over the world
r.i.p vine you will be missed the song
used by the way is my boo by ghost town
deejays outside of the battle past these
sorcerers appeared
elmira in particular looks familiar to
me probably due to those glasses I'm
sure you all know where I'm going with
this one so after three let's have our
hagrid impressions you ready one two
three you're a wizard Larry a wizard
with those glasses and that jawline this
has to be Harry Potter inspired and to
compound that there's an emote called
Slytherin which I'm told is some sort of
house inside Hogwarts is now a good time
to admit that I've never seen a Harry
Potter film sorry
the color scheme used on these
characters once again made me think past
the obvious and from doing these videos
for over a year now I've noticed that
the design team start with a concept but
then they add to it from other genres
you know I've been hunting through
Disney films at the moment well did you
ever watch Fantasia Mickey Mouse was The
Sorcerer's Apprentice and spotted a
lovely red
and blue hat just like Elmyra in the
film Mickey uses his powers to summon
objects to complete his chores for
tonight make homage the bat in this
emote what really impressed me is that
the objects in the cartoon become
uncontainable and Mickey doesn't know
how to stop them then he pulls out an
axe and smashes everything to
smithereens just like we do in every
single game of war at night and speaking
of Disney films this season will forever
be remembered for the Easter egg ad
risky reels wreck-it Ralph shows up for
a split second as he ventures around the
internet it confused the hell out of me
the first time I saw it and the hot
Moratti mulch we receive for free is
indeed from wreck-it Ralph - when Ralph
is attempting to complete all fortnight
emotes he's only on screen for a few
seconds but it's a nice - a char the
same the way things are going Disney
will probably buy Epic Games and own the
entire world season 6 brought us new
mechanics to experience with the most
noticeable a freaking cyclone around the
flying house on top of that we could
throw tomatoes at each other and use
shadow stones to quickly travel hidden
within visibility at the end of the
season permanent rifts became apparent
and even portals were added in wailing
woods the game continued to evolve and
each week the meta change making a year
old game feel brand new constantly not
enough credit is given for that skill
Bravo Epic Games employs
let's quickly run through the map
updates for the season I'll do my best
to be quick as I've mentioned portals
were added in wailing woods but it was
updated to include more cabins and the
bunkers we've been waiting to see opened
since season 3 the floating island held
a small Easter egg with the bones
indicating a monster once lived under
the surface of loot Lake the Loch Ness
monster is real I guess or was real I
suppose a castle was added above haunted
hills which nobody used except me so I'm
expecting it to be destroyed by the end
of season 9 down in fatal figures the
farmers finally figured out how to grow
crops it only took a year
congratulations to them a cool Halloween
minecraft Easter egg could be found with
the face of a creeper in those crops
speaking of Halloween the map continued
to update to include more and more
Halloween inspired junk in people's
houses and Gardens in real life we all
know that one person on the street who
takes Halloween for far too seriously
and yet the hearing 492 as well as
additions and new locations some areas
were now derelict the absolutely
mind-blowing locations from season four
like villains rocket lair in the
mountains or the heroes mansion were now
shells of their former glory so once
again they'll probably be removed in the
next season or two thanks for the
memories especially the rocket event
that was so damn good during the latter
stages of the season chicken feathers
and drumsticks were found in strange
places just in case they aren't called
chicken drumsticks in your country and
referring to these things I'm not
suggesting there's a percussion
challenge to do this week hang on
quickly copyright the idea I digress on
Thanksgiving 2018 the chicken character
was finally introduced meat the tender
defender and his ridiculous glider which
I had to buy by the way use code atom
arrow in the shop to help me feed my
kids and by the occasional pair of new
underwear hmm the tender defender is
actually the work of a fan
reddit user T Faust 10 uploaded a
picture of his son and his concept of a
chicken character named the chicken
trooper the post was loved by the
community and another user Etsy turtle
involved the design into the tender
defender
Epic's loved this redesign so much they
added it to the game giving credit where
it's deserved hopefully this is a sign
that epic are looking to collaborate
with fans and what's great about this is
that those fans will be paid for their
creativity keep an eye out for more in
season 7
let's leave Easter eggs and references
for a moment and take a look back at
season 6 story and the plight of Kevin
the cube at the end of season 5 Kevin
fell in to loot Lake only to rise again
over the season he took the house from
up on a tour of the map but came back
home for his final resting place he gave
us a zombie filled game world with
though shadow stones we were talking
about many people hated this experiment
but I personally liked the inclusion of
husks from save the world following that
week it was finally time to say goodbye
to Kevin here are his final moments in
the world
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you want to see all live events in
real time I'll link a video now but for
now it looks like this chapter of
fortnight is over but we didn't have to
wait long for the next event to start as
a mysterious parachute was found on top
of flush factory with a suspicious mark
upon it over the next few weeks we saw
aim or aimbot as I prefer to call him
watching the inhabitants of the island
hiding in shadows waiting for season 7
to begin he brought with him a snowstorm
in the distance which grew everyday
closer to the new season we all think
it's an iceberg at this point but will
this hold some sort of Christmas event
or shall we expect a military Santa and
reindeer ninjas you'll already know at
this point but for me it still season
still upsetting this let's have one last
Easter egg for Kevin the cube the way he
was destroyed is the same as the bricks
in Super Mario Odyssey coincidence you
decide oh oh in fact there is actually
one more before I move on the butterfly
we encounter in the alternate dimension
is a nod to the Marvel film Doctor
Strange where Benedict cummerbund
Benedict Kamen lunge
Benedict Cumberbatch whatever it's
called he goes through many different
worlds and timings really intense scenes
but it ends in a very similar way with
him finding this butterfly which brings
him crashing back down to reality Kevin
will be forever immortalized in the back
bling unlocked after the event sadly I
was a way that we can got nothing thank
you brilliant but I did get the og skull
trooper skin which for some reason is
purple come on I pick pink is where it's
at right we're doing well but we need to
power through come on more Easter eggs
and references the battle past load
screen for chomp masters is a nod to the
film jaws he's definitely gonna need a
bigger boat the dance emote smooth moves
is in homage to the bangtan boys or BTS
for short these are a South Korean
boyband that recently appeared on The
Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon
to take part in a fortnight dance
challenge the smooth moves imholte
takes elements from their dance routines
in many BTS songs such as save me DNA
mic drop I haven't heard any of these
does the character ruckus remind you of
anything he's part of the wasteland
warriors he's actually a nod to many
post-apocalyptic movies but one video
game in particular Borderlands and the
psychos in that world his gas-mask
psychotic eyes are over-the-top colors
and even the shoulder pads and hand
spikes ring true as a Borderlands fan I
adore this bottle and 3 confirmed 2019
arguably an overwatch character popped
up this season arachnid is it just me or
does she look just like Widowmaker right
all we need now is road punk or Tim the
top man I do believe they're exactly the
same person let's do some minis good old
memes right at the end of the season the
Mothman appeared complete with lamp this
is in recognition of the moth meme who
can't resist the lamps light this
generation is so messed up stay that way
it makes life more fun the tipos meme
also appeared this season and I have no
idea how to explain this to my fellow
old people the tipos is a stance in many
video games which characters revert you
as it's used for mocap but we usually
see in some sort of glitch
thanks to those pesky young people and
Photoshop the pose became about
dominance and well see for yourself
things got weird right let's end with
the saxophone that this is firstly a
bloody grating mulch but it pays homage
to a few real-life sax players the first
of course is the epic sax guy
I'm sure you've already seen him pop up
in twitch email SOG when someone
subscribes on YouTube or something like
that but he's actually a real-life
musician who performed in the Eurovision
Song Contest how the heck do I surmised
the Eurovision Song Contest
hmm Eurovision is a singing contest
where each European country puts forward
a musical act which is voted on
throughout the continent oh and if you
didn't know Australia is in Europe yeah
things make no sense here oh yeah epic
sax guy he performed BOM Moldova back in
2010 and his enthusiasm made him a hero
for us all that's what happens when we
witness unprotected sex come on I waited
a whole video to do one jerk that's it
but that's not the end of that emotes
heritage if you know a band called too
many zoos are lucky chops you'll
recognize the other steps in the emote
if you get a chance please watch Leo
Pellegrino at the Proms in 2017
he has pink hair nuff said
right I finished for Easter egg hunting
this season what did I miss
this video was paid for by those lovely
people who used my code in the supporter
creator event honestly without game talk
to Moshe
you guys make it possible for me to
actually spend time on real videos
rather than churning out with baked so I
appreciate that thank you very much
anyway juicy a time I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade let's see what that
iceberg brings in season 7
[Music]
[Music]